long time ago i grew up in the atlantic
city area i grew up around all the
gangsters of the era in the late 70s
early 80s
you know i've res i revolved around
these the the sun 47 almost 48 times now
and i've learned a thing or two
but even growing up in that era i knew
these guys were some serious guys and
they did some bad stuff and you kind of
got an idea that they were
they were up to no good but you were
just a kid you know i was friends with
all their sons i hung out on george
avenue in atlantic city
and
you you find out real quick that
you better respect these guys they
command it
but what i realized is although they
were bad guys
the worst guy was the guy that i went
home to every night and he wasn't a
gangster that was he was my father
and
he
there's there's something to be said
about physical abuse versus emotional
abuse i can take a punch
you know i'm a pretty tough guy but
emotional abuse especially when you're a
kid
takes a toll on you and you really don't
know how to deal with it you know you
get hit in sports or
or something like that and
you're fine you know you walk it off
we're taught as young boys to walk it
off or up some dirt on it but how do you
do that with an emotional scar
so
although my father
hit me quite frequently
the emotional abuse that he put me
through was probably the worst
my father was a little racist he used to
call me the laziest white man alive
which i still to this day don't
understand because i have friends of
all different races and there's lazy
ones in every every corner of the globe
make you feel really bad in sports if
you did something wrong really
beat your character down and you always
feel like you have this this monster on
your back this thing that you're trying
to run away from and you try to develop
a new identity you figure
if if i become this
then everything at home will be okay
it's not necessarily so so you know
you're growing up
and you think okay maybe if i'm the
tough kid that'll do it maybe that's
gonna do it
well you become the tough kid you get
into a lot of fights
and does it do it nope nope so
you know what maybe i'll be the smart
kid that'll do it that's what everybody
wants that's what everybody wants to me
you're constantly searching for this
identity
nope doesn't do it then you go on to
drugs and you go on to petty theft you
know i might most of my friends growing
up were thieves breaking into houses
breaking into cars stealing everything
that wasn't nailed down
but maybe if i stole
enough i'd be able to fill this this
hole that was created
by such a toxic home environment
and you know when you when you try to
fill stuff something in that hole inside
of you and you realize that doesn't do
it you move on to the next thing and the
next thing and the next thing
when things got tough
and that's not your true identity what
do you do you run away from things
time moves on i grow up and i had the
opportunity to go to college i was
pretty bright kid
and i go away and i pick a college that
was two and a half hours away it was the
furthest college at the time
that
would that accepted me and i jumped on
it
i just wanted to leave this this life
behind i didn't i didn't want to be a
thief i saw some of my friends already
starting to go to jail and getting
arrested for petty stuff
my home life was very toxic my father
very just
not a nice guy not a nice guy
so i run away i run away to college
because when you when you run away to a
different area you get the opportunity
that very few of us are given that's to
reinvent yourself to to really make
something out of nothing you can create
a whole new persona they're going to
believe exactly what you tell them so i
go away to college and i said you know
what
i'm not going to be this guy anymore
i'm going to be somebody new
so i immerse myself in athletics i
immerse myself in the gym and i become
this big bulky guy
thinking okay now this is my identity
this is my identity this is where i'm
going to fit in
and after a while you realize no no so
you run away from that identity
then you get into girls
you know you're always into girls but
college is really when you get into
girls and this girl that i'm with she's
going to be my identity well that's not
true either
so you're constantly searching and
searching you get out of college i found
that i could never go back home there
was nothing for me at home anymore i'm
going to create this new life in north
jersey
uh south jersey is just not for me
anymore
and i really loved it i really did love
it but i was constantly running from
something and i never understood this
until i got a little bit older i was
trying to find myself i was trying to
find my place in this world i had a
feeling that i was
i was destined for something like we all
are you know we're all we all feel like
we're destined for for greatness
but you just got to find it you got to
find your little niche
one day i'm in the i'm in the gym and a
guy comes up to me and he
we're just talking and he says well you
know did you ever think about becoming a
cop
i had never thought about it my brother
you know my brother took police tests
every week trying to become a cop that
was his dream it was never my dream my
dream was to go out and make a
difference in the world
but the way it was sold to me is hey
you're gonna have a pension you're gonna
have benefits you're gonna you're never
gonna be rich but you'll you'll survive
you'll make a good living
and this is probably uh
early 2001.
so i go i i take the test and turns out
i did very well in the test i get the
job it's very rare in the police world
in new jersey to get the job on the
first
first shot out so i was very fortunate
while i was in the police academy
911 happens and the police world changed
you know this
this job that you thought you took it
was just a job
you everything the way you did
everything changed the way your mindset
changed
one of the things about police work
that i found very early on is i took it
as a job and then when i became immersed
in it because this was my new identity i
finally thought that i found my place in
this world
i found out very quickly that it's more
than just arresting bad guys doing car
chases you know locking people up it's
about keeping people safe it's about
giving people hope it's about giving
people a symbol
to
to look towards when they need help and
they don't know where to go it's a it's
it's a wonderful job one of the stories
that jumps out at me is there was a
there was a young woman with a very
young child about four years old child's
name was mason
and she's
ready to end her life she has a knife
with her
we go in there and she won't let anybody
near the kids she certainly won't let
anybody take the kid away
and i'm able to sit there and talk to
her i broke a very important role
because there's something called the 25
foot rule that if you get close that
close to somebody with a knife they're
going to be able to stab you before you
can draw your gun out and take care of
things
i felt comfortable enough to do this
this woman was she needed help she
really needed help and i really felt for
this little kid i don't know what it was
about
what was about this little kid that drew
me to him so i sat on the bed next to
her and i talked her
and i'm watching this kid mason
go from hugging his mother
to
really
start just nudging closer nudging closer
and all of a sudden he's right up
against me
that situation ends we get her get her
the help that she needs we send her off
to the hospital we the grandmother was
there we take the kids so everybody's
safe ten years go by and i'm in plain
clothes i'm in the sh i'm in the
supermarket
and i hear hey officer kevin
i'm in plain clothes
turn around and there's a 15 16 year old
kid there
and i said yeah that's my name's kevin
who who are you and he goes well i'm
mason
you help my mom out
and she's getting she's better now she's
better now because of you and he gave me
a big hug and
that's what police work was to me and i
love that job and for a long time after
that
i really felt like i had found my place
and i didn't have to run away anymore
like i did when i was a kid
then july 10 2013 happens
we respond to a
dispute
at a
townhouse complex
and it wasn't uncommon where i worked i
worked in small suburban town
and we go there and we can hear the
arguing
one about one of the officers is in the
back and i'm in the front and as we try
to breach the door
pop pop
it's that holy [ __ ] moment
you fall back you make sure your other
officer is okay i go back around the to
the rear of the building it was a middle
section of a townhouse so there's
an exit in the back and an entrance in
the front
other officers are covering the front
and we get on this little deck
now this guy's already shot at police
once there's no reason why he wouldn't
do it again but we see the victim in
there and again police work is about
protecting people it's about helping
people we have to get to this victim
before
something really bad happens
we throw a chair through the sliding
glass door
and out of nowhere
i see the brightest flash
i've ever seen
i hear a bang
i feel gunpowder hit my face
this guy was right behind the wall we
couldn't see him
pulls his gun around shoots at me
the bullet missed my ear by what they
suspect is about an eighth of an inch
but i know it wiggled my left ear
i hit the ground i have no idea whether
i'm shot or not
i looked down
the other officers on the deck at that
time were able to get off i looked down
i see a lot of blood
other officers are asking me if i'm shot
and i said you know what i i don't know
i don't know i see a lot of blood my
shoulder hurts
but i'm trapped where i am on this deck
i can't get out if i get out he's going
to be able to shoot
so i'm stuck
i come to the realization very quickly
that i'm going gonna die
and if i'm gonna die
you're coming with me
i get into a prone position very calm
very clear
i think of my kids i had a
three-year-old i had a seven month old
my seven month old will never know me my
three-year-old only had vague
recollections of me
i say goodbye to him
i uh i wish i would be there just to
kiss him good night one more time
and i get ready to die i get ready to
shoot it out with this guy
by the grace of god the other officers
were able to reach over top grab my belt
cover the front door and get me out
at this time the the assailant goes
upstairs the victim were able to get the
victim out that's a great job we did our
job we protected life
nobody got hurt seriously
i go to the hospital get glass removed
from my arm
and the the police department tells me
hey you know you want to i was working
wednesday thursday says hey why don't
you take thursday off i come back monday
i figured great i got a four-day
vacation it was a great job
you know i'm amped up i can't go to
sleep i sleep a little bit but i don't
really get good sleep i wake up to 50
phone calls about what happened that's
you know police police works about it's
like a big sewing circle
and everything's cool everything's fine
my wife is just beside herself
that you know she can't believe what
happened but she's thankful that i'm
home
so we go to the movies
thursday night this event happen on a
wednesday we go to movies thursday night
and everything's fine
we're watching a comedy it's a seth
rogen comedy called this is the end
and in there is a there's a scene with a
big bang
i still feel what it was like in that
movie theater
my heart started racing i started
pouring sweat couldn't breathe
i didn't want to alert my wife because
she'd been through enough i didn't want
to alert her about what what was going
on so i just tell her like i'm going to
go up and go to the bathroom i
my stomach hurts a little bit
i go outside and i can't catch my breath
i can't stop sweating i can't stop
shaking
i've never felt anything like this
before in my entire life
i can't go back into the movie theater
it's like i'm paralyzed after about 15
minutes she comes out and says you know
are you okay i said yeah you know my
stomach's hurt and she wants to go back
and sit down i'll be in a little bit she
goes now let's let's go home
well that night
i had about the worst nightmare i could
ever have i woke up so wet drenched in
sweat that i actually had to check to
see if i pissed myself
and then subsequently after that every
night was just nightmare after nightmare
after nightmare
what i realize right now is that's the
onset of of pts and i want to make this
very clear is it's post-traumatic stress
it's not a disorder
it's not a disorder you weren't born
with this a disorder is something you're
born with this is a brain disease it's a
brain injury the synapses in your brain
actually become damaged because of the
trauma you you see
it goes on and on we we go down to see
my parents who still lived in the
atlantic city area to bring the kids
down
and my son spills chocolate milk he's
three years old he spills chocolate milk
on his on his car seat and i lost my
mind
it was so bad on the ride home
that my wife was begging me
to pull over and let her and the kids
out
i was this just maniac
that night i realized that there's a
serious problem and i need to get some
help i try to go get some help and they
send you to the doctors and you know the
doctors medicate you and
i
i was supposed to go back to work on
that monday i was in the doctor's office
because i had a bunch of glass in my arm
and that's where the blood was coming
from i wasn't shot
but the the doctor's picking glass out
of my arm
and i remember her asking me
she goes are you okay and i said yeah
you know i'm all right it's just it's
just a little bit of glass it's not a
big deal she goes no that's not what i
mean are you okay
i'm not a crier
you know i've i consider myself pretty
tough
you would have thought that i lost
the most important person in the world
to me i started crying and bawling in
that doctor's office
to where the doctor actually gave me a
hug it's very rare for a doctor to break
that
that patient boundary and she did she
gave me a hug
and i didn't know i i didn't understand
these feelings i didn't understand what
the heck was going on all i know is i
wasn't right
time moves on the nightmares are still
going
and i realize that some things have
changed in me
thunder and lightning storms this was
july so the thunder and lightning storms
were common
and when thunder happened
i was ready to go [ __ ] my pants i
couldn't deal with it i actually would
go and hide in a closet
when the thunder would happen
um i couldn't watch movies with guns
i couldn't hear any loud like fireworks
forget it fireworks will send me under
the covers in a closet just hiding away
i was i was changing i was changing i
couldn't sleep
i was up
majority of the night
and one day my son he's a three-year-old
he's got nerf guns hanging around he's
playing around points a nerf gun at me
well there's a maneuver that the police
will do when somebody
you're taught it when somebody's
pointing a gun at you you grab it like
this real quick and then you pull it
away from them and it's it's a blink of
an eye you practice it so much it's it's
muscle memory
i do that to him and i rip it right out
of his hands
i take it snap it in two
and i remember that look
and for people who have children they
know that blank look that that child
gets i scared the hell out of my three
or a three-year-old
what did i just do he's standing me with
his mouth open and i snapped into a
throat in the
throat in the garbage i don't say
anything to him
i walk out of the house now
prior to this i had never carried my
off-duty gun off you know when i wasn't
working it's a liability i'm not real
big fan of guns anyway so i never
carried it but i started carrying it
because i wasn't sleeping i was getting
paranoid um the guy who shot at me
he was in custody but
he uh
my brain was wired wrong
so i started carrying my off-duty gun
it was a little uh chief special 38
nickel plated with lightning grips
beautiful just gorgeous gun little five
shot
after i broke the gun
on my son
i just walked out of the house
i went and lived in the woods for three
days
hung out against a tree took my cell
phone threw it in my car parked my car
in a different section
and uh i didn't want anybody to find me
and just thought and i don't think i
slept for three days
because i had to get out of the house
who are you going to talk to about this
stuff there's nobody there's no there's
nobody is going to understand you
nobody's going to
going to understand these these these
random thoughts going on in your head
and you're not sleeping i started
drinking which i'm not a big drinker i
wasn't a big drinker but i started
drinking because i just needed some
something to just calm me down i
i started drinking more than i can
possibly imagine it'd be nothing for me
to
to drink a fifth
wash down with a couple other things
whatever i could find and don't forget
i'm medicated also
so i'm on a cocktail of an
antidepressant and anti-anxiety and the
anti-anxiety was kalonopin and it says
very clearly on the bottle don't drink
on kalonopin
i found out real quick that if you take
a couple kalonopen and drink you can get
twice as drunk
with less alcohol
scary thought don't it's really bad it
could have some it can really hurt you
but at that point i didn't really care
i was starting to think that i'm just
becoming this monster and i'm starting
to think that
i don't belong here anymore i'm supposed
to be stronger than this i was really
mad at myself you're stronger than this
kevin you can do this
and i was out of control
yelling at my wife spitting at my wife
calling her every name in the book
she couldn't relate to me i just stopped
sleeping in a bed because i was either
if i did sleep i was having night
terrors or i was so wet that when i woke
up i had to change the sheets so i
started sleeping downstairs
i can't live like this anymore i
i need to go away
i need to remove myself from the
situation
the common misperception with police is
if i die while i'm working my wife will
get three and a half times my salary
she'll get benefits for the rest of her
life i'm here to tell you that's not
true
it's it's one of the biggest farces and
lies that we tell ourselves along with
that same lie that the world is better
off without us
but i thought the world was better off
without me you're in a dark place you
just
there's no rational thoughts
trying to rationalize
uh suicidal thoughts is is you're trying
to rationalize an irrational behavior
so one morning about 2 am
i walk into my office which was just a
converted bedroom
i take my my gun
which again i never let my wife know
that i was
i was holding this gun i was carrying
this gun
and this was the time
that i was going to remove myself from
the situation i was going to kill myself
i write the
note i say goodbye to everybody and in
my note i'm just that type of guy where
i don't want to leave a mess behind
so i give passwords to the bank you know
and
things that need to be done like a you
know like a rundown list of everything
that i take care of in the household
how the bills are paid and
and i i just i'm ready to go you know
i say you know tell my kids when i was
older that i tried the best i could
i'm sorry that i'm such a disappointment
i'm sorry i turned into this person
[Music]
but you don't deserve this
i still have that note
i don't think i'll ever let anybody read
it
i take the end of the gun
and i can taste the metal on my tongue i
can feel the
the sight
on my teeth
and it's a double action gun so when you
cocked a hammer back
it's it's it's only
the the gun itself is only 1.9 ounce or
1.9 pounds something somewhere around
there so it's real light but it feels
like it's it's a lead weight in your
hand
like it takes gunpowder on my tongue too
and i cocked that hammer back and when
you [ __ ] a hammer back it's the
slightest touch and boom it's go time
and i replay the incident in my head
and i'm just i'm i'm looking for a
reason
to not do this but i can't find one
nothing is coming to me i'm just going
through all the the [ __ ] that i just put
my family through and this is i'm
probably
four
or five weeks removed from the shooting
i'm not that same person you can see it
in my eyes my whole body has changed
squeeze i start squeezing the trigger
tighter and tighter and tighter just
waiting for the bang
you know because i figure in my mind
once that bang happens
it's just going to be lights out i'm not
going to see anything i'm not going to
have to feel this pain anymore that i
feel this this internal struggle this
emotional pain
at the end i have this brief moment
of clarity
uh some people think it's their higher
power calling some people think it's
just
a pause
i don't know i don't know i'd like to
think that it's somebody telling me that
i'm not done yet
i hold the gun in my hand and i just
stare at it for probably 15 minutes
going oh my god
and i start thinking now now that moment
of clarity let me think i'm like if i
just did this my kids are going to come
down and find me find their father with
their head half their head missing
because i always had hollow point
bullets
what a horrible thing to do
yeah that was that was the first time
that i tried to kill myself
other times
as i told you before that if you take
colonopin and drink it's a very
dangerous cocktail
you can kill yourself
i knew this
so
i'm drinking all day because i can't
work i can't go obviously i'm never
going back to the police department
i take a handful of clown pit i must
have taken
out anywhere from 10 to 15 whatever
whatever i could pour out
and i start drinking
and
just drink and drink and drink
and then everything if you've ever
passed out you see the darkness just
close in on you like this
you know and you just pass out
well the downside of that was i woke up
and i woke up in a pretty bad mood
because once again
i was unsuccessful
there were other times too i i tried to
hang myself
with a uh with a dog leash
at that time i went out in the woods
tried to drive uh you know you're
driving down the road and you're just
thinking well you know what if i just
fly off this bridge
that'll do it
um
let me try that gun again
but the problem with the gun is is i
knew i was in trouble and i didn't want
to do it but i did not want to kill
myself but i found no other way so i
took my gun and i i shipped it off to a
friend of mine and said hey look you got
to hold on to this i can't be trusted
with this stuff
and it just goes on and on like that
just drinking and drinking and drinking
just wondering how long i'm going to be
able to do this
i started going to some group therapy
and
specifically with other officers and
there's something that i found out i'm
not the only one going through all these
things i'm not the only one that's
having all these thoughts there's other
people involved that are
that other people who have been in
similar incidents who are going through
almost identical things that that i'm
going through
i can't you know i'm like wow this is
this is incredible
um
and through that group therapy i just
each day you know i would
go to group therapy come home and i'd be
able to sleep
i i you know in in six months time i
probably slept a total of 24 hours
i started getting some help i started
getting some genuine help and then i
realized the biggest lie
i ever told myself as i said before was
the world's better off without me
the world is not better off without me
because as i got through this and got
help from these other people
i realized that i'm not alone
other people understand these feelings
where i thought nobody nobody could
understand these feelings
so i was on my way back
i was able to retire
and get my pension and thankfully i was
able to to get my pension
and i realized once i was through you
haven't you have a an option once you
retire you can stop going to group
therapy and say hey look i'm cured i'm
fine but if you were able to do that
uh you're you're a fraud you're a phony
because now you owe it to yourself
to take what you've learned
and pay it forward to other people
and give what you've what people gave to
you and pay it forward because those
people don't want anything back they
want it they want you to to go forward
so i continue going to group therapy and
i see this this cadre of people coming
in and you can just see that look in
their eye there that that stare you're
like yeah you're you're about to
you're really about to go on this ride
and there's nothing i can say but what i
can do
is i can walk alongside of you
from a place of understanding because i
have been there
and i made it out to the other side see
when you're in the darkest times of your
life you're in this dark tunnel and you
think there's nobody around you nobody
understands you're all alone
it's not until you get towards the end
when a little bit of light shines in and
you look to your right and your left and
there are people walking through with
you
and
they're helping you out it's just it's
so dark in there
and
what i realized very quickly was
what happened after this incident is no
different than what happened in my
childhood
i just ran away from my problems the
same way i ran away from home and went
to college the same way i tried to
change identities and run away from who
i was before
that's all i was doing
but i was numbing it alcohol
prescription medication
uh trying to trying to kill myself
that was just a temporary fix
i had to face the problem i had to turn
around and
hug this suffering of mine
and i did
i faced it head-on i had to go back and
repair a lot of different relationships
in my way my life i'd repair the
relationship with my wife i'd repaired a
relationship with my friend with my with
my uh children with my friends who just
thought i fell off the the map
and i started to find some peace and
hope
when i went out there and and started
helping other people through the same
situations that i went through
you know we're we're born
with a with a glass
and in that glass
is the amount of suffering and pain and
just crap that we can handle
and with each
piece of pain that comes in the glass
gets a little fuller and a little fuller
a little fuller and you hope that by the
end of your life that glass doesn't
overflow
because you hoped that that glass was
made big enough by your maker where you
can handle all this stuff my glass
spilled over my glass spilled over
i've learned to empty the glass now so
when the glass starts getting a little
full
i just give that suffering a big hug
so i found a lot of peace and hope in
helping others around me and helping
people around me
um deal with their pain
because as police officers and as as
just the the regular citizen
you know every piece of pain and damage
we see we we stack on another piece of
armor and another piece of armor and
another piece of armor
and before you know it after 20 years
you're so heavily laden with armor
because these different pains you don't
ever want to get hurt like that again so
you guard yourself against it you can't
even stand up because you're so weighted
down with armor
but when i started telling other people
the journey that i went through the pain
that i went through
i found very quickly that a piece of
armor will pop off and wow that feels
pretty good it's like doing a 20-year
squat in the gym you know once that
barbell comes off your back
you're pretty light
and that's what i did
i would go out and tell my story and
tell my story and somehow my story gave
people some hope
and that identity that i was looking for
that thing that i was running away from
i seem to have found it in in my new
purpose
is
helping people helping other people
because that's ultimately where we're on
this earth once we we all have an
expiration date it's what we do when
we're here
that makes a difference you know
everybody has peaks and valleys in their
life
and just because you're high right now
doesn't mean tomorrow you're not going
to be in that valley
and then the next day you might be up
again
i want everybody to realize that just
because you're in a valley right now
doesn't mean that you got to stay in a
valley
and that there's purpose in your
suffering
it's a it's about helping people through
and showing them that there is purpose
in this in this life purpose in their in
their pain and their suffering you know
i i i learned to embrace
my pain
and i use the i use the terminology
i read this book years ago it was about
how to survive worst case scenarios and
i think i was on a business trip or
something
and one of them was a prairie fire
and now i'm in new jersey there's no
prairie fires in new jersey but
when you see a prairie fire coming to
you it's it's human instinct to run away
from danger that's just how we're built
that's how we're designed it's it's
survival
with a prairie fire though if you run
away from it it's just going to grow and
grow and grow
until it becomes so big that it's going
to consume you and you're ultimately
going to die but all you had to do is
run straight towards that prairie fire
and you'll get through to the other side
you'll be a little scarred you'll be a
little charred but ultimately you're
going to be alive
and we tell people we walk people
through to have them run to their
suffering not away from it don't numb it
don't numb it you would never know
anything good in life if you didn't know
the bad
and because you know the bad in a way
that some people can't imagine
you're going to have so much better
perspective on the good things in life
you're going to appreciate that meal a
little bit more than the average person
you're going to appreciate your
relationship with your kid or your
spouse
a little bit more than most people in
life
and
it's worked
it's really worked because then people
will listen to it and say you know what
i i can relate to that person
so we're doing a group therapy session
on air
every week
with
thousands of people
and the the suffering podcast has has
just been
so great that i'm able to smile again
i i went probably seven six seven years
with rarely smiling and definitely very
few genuine smiles
and now i have a genuine smile on my
face i'm a happy guy now i found that
primary identity the one thing about
primary identity that thing that i was
always chase always chasing
you know primary identities have to be
my good friend pastor adam burke
primary identity it has to be unshakable
and he's taught me this
i used to think my primary identity was
being a tough guy or
being the the best at sports or being
the biggest drug addict or
or being uh the best sport play or the
the highest educated person in college
or even being a cop i always thought
that was my identity but all those
things have an expiration date
every single one of them has an
expiration date so you need to find
something that is your primary identity
and only you can find it nobody can tell
you what it is you need to find your
primary identity in something that's
never going to move whether it's a
belief in your higher power or whether
it's a belief in your children or your
spouse
something that is well even your spouse
is shakeable but
you need to find something that is
totally unshakable in your life and then
everything else you are falls underneath
that primary identity so when those
things expire
you still have that one unshakable thing
at the top
helping others is where it's at isn't it
you know it that's all it is that's what
we're put on this earth to do we're not
put on this earth for personal gain
we're put on this earth to help our
fellow
human being
what a great talk kevin thank you thank
you
you